welcome to this video playing carrom ass
off I think this is how it is should be
pronounced Nikolai and no Ritson okay I
don't have a good score again sir let's
see okay I got them Russell limo Queenie
too okay wasn't the way that this is a
moves in this position but ok it's it's
not bad of course covers cavity for and
so on so what is black doing here am I
going to play with d 6 or how what D 5 D
5v5 maybe d6 probably de force coming so
also probably five yeah thats its also a
move just blocking against deform I mean
white cannot win a pond with Bishop
takes Knight takes after rupee eight so
this is some taking the shape of the of
a rillo personal in a couple of roofs
quite funny but this sometimes happens
out of the the Russell emo d4 since idea
so I'm going to put the rook on the
e-file that d 4 is really never possible
okay this also fits into the position
almost all of the time
so yeah you still cannot play deform
yeah I wonder if d 5 is a move but I
doubted still just developing now maybe
after Bishop is 6 the d4 move gains a
little bit and strength but not probably
it doesn't okay so Queen to be six
probably attacking the bishop preparing
group d 8 and then ultimately d5 look 28
no
yeah d 5 maybe I really get to play that
I know maybe I should have played a
little bit more forcefully like Queen a
six then d5 directly okay yeah if I'm
allowed to play that I will I really
didn't see how he could have maybe
prevented it but just in general terms
if I can if I'm able to break like that
it's something a chance that black
should them should take okay how do I
play here d 4 or not yeah it gains quite
some space queen a 6 is also the
possible capture on e4 that's an
interesting idea maybe Bishop c2 takes
pawn takes Queen takes Knight takes
bishop g four wins upon and Tim I'm not
sure if he really likes to take with the
PCM yeah I mean he has to probably but
it's not necessarily great so c4 or is
this bad yeah it's got 95 coming
ppai Queen f3 maybe okay maybe this some
wasn't the greatest datos greatest
transformation here queen of three is a
somewhat problematic move for Knight f6
check mmm well not easy and my night
hangs on c6
man what did I do wrong here what's this
transformation wrong with details before
maybe maybe that was wrong ya hear ya i
really have no good good move it's just
like that i have no move whatsoever just
it's just very bad this position what
can you do just very bad amazing how
quickly that was downhill
as climb morning Green age form that was
it was especially stupid him I thought
that while King age seven I mean not
that it is great but Queen age for it's
a very quick way to to end the game now
nothing much I can do
and kind of curious what did I do wrong
after 94 after 95 it's ok b6 is probably
bad but what what exactly should i do
then in this position
we had really curious play what what I
did what I did wrong there because we're
frankly I shouldn't fight for equality
but for an advantage in this position
and it was it was just very very bad
when I got it so high it's got c4 I have
no time so seaforth sc4 was of course
stronger it's still so bad
any any idea here 96 f 4 maybe I only
have some seconds left
okay that's if that's a piece I cannot
cannot do it on time anyway black eyes
I'm also far more curious about the
position here I mean come on does this
must be okay for black right so okay d
for the clear advantage instead of
taking and that was my first first
instinct actually deform just grab the
space I mean that that cannot be good
what why did ya like losing tons of time
doubling the pawn and so on it must be
it must be okay for me everything's
right on the black side got everything
centralized and so on Saudi for was
right yeah well this was my first idea
but I mean not that I'm winning or
anything but white has some issues now
probably see foil and b5 well it's just
nice for black people I have no problem
whatsoever and have an initiative this
is what stockbridge is giving 0.64 black
so nothing nothing spectacular but I
mean this is kind of what is right after
he has played played it's also strangely
it's amazing how quickly it goes
downhill after the caption I only took
three seconds for that yeah the reason
was that I saw Queen a six ticks and I
was kind of fascinated that I'm actually
winning winning a poor Nia but of course
he takes with the night and this
wouldn't be that bad if it weren't for
concrete reasons I mean yeah I mean on
paper well this looks like a target and
so on but the problem is just it's very
concrete I have this I have to do
something about this attack and I cannot
really cover this in a good way this
this looks bad now maybe queen bee too
can be played but it doesn't look right
John how do I cover the pawn check it's
not the solution be 60 I know queena
three yeah what the computer wants to go
g5 and says equal wow that is very hard
to believe I'm a little bit little bit
stunned by the movie 5 check check now
it wants to simply take and this is
supposed to be equal what that's that's
really tough to believe okay I'm
threatening Queenie 6 with the with the
Queen trap huh rook rook is six with the
Queen show and then this is this is the
computers line and courts this equal hmm
can't that stuff okay that was difficult
difficult to imagine I mean I saw that
I'm basically lost here after Quincy
eight but I can 'it's didn't see I
didn't see an alternative it's just
terribly bad this position so i have to
go d4 yeah i was too tempted by this d
take c form know if you look at it with
them let's say with a clear head after
the game then some things are pretty
logical and when you go d 4 instead of
taking the night on g3 remains the sorry
piece that it is yeah just looking at
protected squares and now is it is
pretty pretty obvious that this is
better it's also a big I mean white has
to play savoia if he is not doing that
um I know move like that I'm going see
for myself probably and yet it gets it
starts to get really serious now in
terms of an advantage for black he has
to really do that and then this is this
is just a big space advantage from black
there are also some other ideas yeah
it's it's it takes a while but sometimes
I can also switch over here like the
Queen over here to h4 and g4s not
exactly helping him so this is what I
what I needed to do we are interesting
yeah i didn't i didn't really calculate
it and concretely because when you spin
you just see it 94 which yeah i was just
thinking okay about the porn on d3 and
so on but it's just I don't have a
satisfactory move yeah maybe technically
be six with this g5 business but this is
nothing that you really play for them
and it's totally unnecessary so I really
should have taken a moment here this was
one of those instant moves that are
always criticize but I actually made
this decision when when Queen a6 was
played this um yeah okay thanks for
watching